hey what's up guys Samuel Leeds here and
on this video I'm gonna set myself a
challenge I'm gonna try and answer ten
questions in ten minutes this is gonna
be speed round from the previous Q&A
Sunday so hope you enjoy and if this
triggers other questions comment them
below now try and answer them for next
week
so it's not enough where Lewis Clark he
says Sami what I was wondering what age
can you start doing HMOs at HMOs you
don't need to be any different age
between heroes and just normal
buy-to-let all i've got my first house
at 17 and believe it or not it was a HMO
because i rent it out by the room
how did i do that i put it in someone
else's name and how to set up whereby
when i was old enough it would be
transferred over to me so you can do
anything when you think creatively but
that's my answer
next is it possible to set up a hey
chamo in an article for area since
julius paulo yes it is if you buy a
house in an article for area and then
you convert it to a HTML or change its
used to HMO you will need to get
planning permission which is an absolute
pain so my suggestion is either by an
existing HMO once it's an article for
area but you'll pay the price for doing
that the best thing to do is to buy a
house before it becomes an article for
area of which there's currently dozens
and dozens of areas in england so buy a
house before it becomes article 4 and
turn it to a high HMO then let article 4
come in and then you have the
grandfather rights on the planning
permission
that's what how you make the most money
in HMOs dan bright like samuel i'm
coming to the crash course at the end of
the month would you advise me taking out
a loan for mentorship like your academy
or any other training program thanks i
would only suggest taking it a loan for
anything
it's the the thing is an asset that's
gonna make you money so if you're taking
out a loan for a house to rent out you
can take out a loan presumably you'll
place a small interest maybe 5% maybe
10% but then you're gonna put that into
something that's going to give you money
which is gonna cover the interest
payments and more that's called good
debt bad debt is when you take out a
loan and you buy it there's something
that's just going to be gone so if the
training is really good training and if
you are going to implement it and the
result is it's going to make you money
then yes however I wouldn't say to
anyone how you should take out a loan
from my course because it's a bit like
you know I want to be able to sleep at
night but if you're confident that
you're going down to make money then
it's a good debt so yes all right next
Alexander Philemon on ice I know how do
you find a good solicitor and how do you
tell a good one from a bad one
okay real simple if I can understand her
solicitor they speak plain English and
they do what they say they well if I
make an appointment to speak to them
they answer the phone at the time we
agreed I'll usually ask them as well
I'll ask them how quick they usually are
do you want someone that's going to be
on the ball and FASTA mother can speak
your language but ultimately if you just
get if you just find a house and use a
solicitor even if this list is not like
a brilliant sister not the best in the
country
it's quite easy a solicitors job she
just completely on a normal transaction
it'd be nice with really complex that's
when you need to get someone really
really good and I just use someone based
on experience who've I used before
they're still a good job but when you
star in small it doesn't matter too much
maybe go for recommendation referrals
during life property investors with Sam
your legs face book group so what's the
lowest amount of money that you'd be
able to start off in property nothing
you don't need money to stay in property
what you need is you need knowledge and
you need a network and most things don't
necessarily cost money or they don't
have to know pump if you agree on a
lease option agreement with a seller do
you have the rights to sell the property
yes you do have the rights to tell a
property as long as it's in the contract
at least optional agreements just a
buoyant piece of paper it's whatever you
and the seller agree and that's just to
draw up if you agree that you can sell
all the option to saw else at the end of
the contract if you agree that from the
beginning then you can sell it on
German ammo knocks carbide Yau do you
have experience from setting up
corporations so that the government
doesn't with your taxes listen rather
than focusing on having to pay taxes I
focus on making money but I see a lot of
people and they're worried about making
lots of money because they're thinking
then I'm gonna have to pay taxes listen
I'd rather make a pound and pay fifty P
to the government then make ten P and
pass nothing to the government for me
I'm all about making more money once I'm
making the money then I'll save more so
yes I do do clever things and my tax
advisers and specialists and accountants
do do clever things to offset losses
against my profits but it's not
something that I have in the forefront
of my mind when I'm starting out to make
money for me it's about how can I make
the most
blue water ice and I'm currently in an
apprenticeship with only 6,000 pounds in
my bank I really want to get started in
property and student accommodation is
looking like an absolute when how well
do you think someone like me can achieve
this with a limited money and income PS
I'll start working full wage soon so
I'll have better income if you're an
apprentice and you've got six grams and
you love the idea of in student
accommodation what I would say is I mean
some people that I know maybe you're a
practicing your law student but I know
students that have got no money you an
apprentice with six thousand and what
they do is they rent a house off a
landlord they pay the landlord six
hundred pounds a month for a big house
and then they rent the other rooms out
to their mates so they're living
rent-free or making noise profit just
because they were the one that initiated
the contract they were the one that took
the risk by renting the whole house an
entrepreneur is someone that takes a
risk in the hope to make money so you
can do the same thing you could rent
somewhere and then rent the rooms out or
if you're thinking I would want to live
with students do the same but don't live
in it just rent the house off the
landlords pay him a monthly fee he only
has to deal with one person you and him
but then you deal with many people and
with the rooms out to students then
you're making a monthly cash flow you
don't own the house on your next door
and once you make it some cash flow
maybe do the same again but ask the
landlord over he'll give you an option
to buy the property down the line that's
what I'll be thinking for you rent to
rent lease option Jorge Auster's says me
and the girlfriend are currently saving
up a hundred thousand pounds to put down
60 thousand pounds plus as a deposit or
even buy our first house cash then we
want to save up cash but straightaway I
can see that your your mindset is not
correct
let me want to save cash save money okay
I'll keep reading I'll give you the
benefit Adele we want to save up cash
and buy our rental properties saving up
cash to buy rental properties is a very
slow way to win you probably not win
unless you happen to be in a business or
a job where you're making an absolute
fortune and you're making lots of cash
fast it's not a good strategy I know
it's better financially to use the
bank's money you've already watched my
videos but I don't think I wouldn't like
the extra stress and worry about having
debt having debt just
makes me feel sick you need to just get
your head straight I understand what
you're saying
about how you don't want to have debt
because it makes you feel stressed but
listen the banks are lending money at 3%
the banks are lending money at 4% and
you can fix it for 10 years unless you
are completely financially illiterate or
you haven't been on my crash course you
should be able to make fifteen twenty
percent plus return on investment which
means that you can borrow the bank's
money at ten years fixed interest at
four percent and then make fifteen
twenty percent extra cash flow plus you
own the house a parents teacher that
debt is bad because they don't know the
difference between good and bad debt but
what I would really say to you George is
you need to just spend some time really
studying this logically studying the
best commercial think the reason you
that debt makes you feel sick maybe is
because you don't trust yourself maybe
you think I don't know if I can make the
right investment so that I couldn't
sleep and the reason you have not got
confidence is because probably you
haven't got the knowledge that you need
if you have the right knowledge and how
to invest and you trusted yourself you'd
love it because you'd know how to use it
as a tool to go make a lot of money but
honestly with without debt you will
never be successful in this business I
don't know any multimillionaires or
people that are killing it in business
or property that don't utilize debt so
look one before you do anything get this
point fixed last one
Marcus Moore well I own a building
company built from the ground up excuse
the pun over a decade of experience
qualified electrician by trade and
completely disagree with your opinion oh
all the bill or a key question I don't
member what that was we create our own
work that's why you are having issues
what I think you're describing is a
master builder instead of regular
builders there is a difference just like
gold dust that's all thanks for the
content that wasn't really question I
said more statement but hey Marcus more
sounds like you're a fantastic builder
if you want to come on the channel and
talk about how to find a good builder
drop me a message or we can chat I did
in ten minutes ten questions / comments
in 10 minutes
hope that was really helpful folks
there's nothing I love more this is one
of my favorite videos than just reading
your comments and your questions and do
videos responding I do read every single
comment that I get on youtube I do it
every single comment and I try at least
given love for a little response to
every single comment but if you would
- come on the YouTube channel or have me
call you out on the YouTube channel
answer your questions or comment below
let me know your questions let me know
what's happening and thank you so much
for watching I'll see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]